GET ON THE GROUND!!
Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Prison Architect.
Ok, we gotta find the drurgs
because there's a lot of drugs going on here.
And I don't know what kind of profit this
whole organization could've possibly made...
Why is this still not powered?
I did good on get power to that. (nice english, markimoo)
Oh, it's not available yet. Never mind then.
We're good, it's fine, everything's fine.
Ok, so I need to get
Uuuuummm.
More guards to help speed up the search,
but the search is almost done...
I mean, I didn't even need to make these get
WOW, that is a lotta drurgs.
Oh my goodness.
They've just got, oh, *cough*
I thought the janitors were carrying bags of drugs
like that was just cocaine in a bag.
I don't know what drugs are,
I don't do drugs (Oh we know markimoo) *laughs* so I have no idea what's going on.
Ey, how's it goin' everybody?
Welcome to the party.
How you bein'?
This guy doesn't even have a name!
Is his name "Subject Zero"?
She's a notorious criminal who's crimes include;
Piracy, kidnapping, vandalism and murder,
she is also a biotic,
possibly one of the most powerful human biotics alive...
What..! Oh! *realizing that he is dum-dum and doesn't remember Mass Effect*
Oh, of course, it's a Mass Effect reference!
Duh!
How could I not get that?
Maybe because it doesn't look anything like Jack
from Mass Effect.
Oh, I had no idea.
That's amazing.
Good.
That's cool, man.
This must be...
Jason "The Squirrel" Aston,
went completely nuts in a candy store,
when a 12 year old boy,
stole the last package of chocolate-covered peanuts.
He *coughs* reportedly showed no remose after biting 47 people and peeing on...
Wow... ok then..
Alrighty
That might be
a reference to someone
but i'm not 100% sure.
So I apologize if I don't know.
But, anyway, we're gonna hire more guards
because we need to get this done.
Haboink!
Boink,
Boink Boink, Boink,
Boink Boink,
Ok, that should be enough
and that should speed up the process.
Probably more guards than we need
but we still seem to be making a profit
which is the MOST important thing in this.
So...
now we just need to speed it up
so our guys can actually do what they need to do...
If they're doing anything at all.
How do I...
search all of the...
ooOOOOHHH!
Aaaahhh.
Shake down option, where's the shake down?
SHAKEDOWN!
YEAH!
Search underway!
Wooh, that is cool!
Hah, that's a
OH GOD. *realizing that the guys in his prison have a problem*
Uhh, that's TOO MANY THINGS. *receiving a call from the CEO*
OH GOD! (taking things to the extreme, huh markimoo?)
CEO, i'm sorry!
Oh, wow!
Okay..
"On the positive, it's not as bad as it could have been,
but there are definite problems on the drug and alcohol dependency."
What about all the weapons?!
There was knives, shears (baa), blunt objects,
probably poisonous substances,
probably dildos that have been weaponized. (oh god)
"We need to help these men. It's the only way of curbing their activities and dealing with their symptoms.
Start a drug treatment program in the infirmary. Our doctors will administer a chemical substitute that will help alleviate the cravings in our addicts."
That's awfully heartwarming and nice.
I thought you were gonna come and tell me to build more electric chairs.
"For the alcoholics, there isn't a chemical substitute, so I suggest we start with group therapy sessions."
Y'all have...yo...y'all.
"Y'all have to build a new common room to run those meetings.
To start new programs, go to 'Reports' in the bottom right of the screen, then 'Programs'.
Anytime you're unsure of what to do, highlight the objective and" blah blah blah we got this gone.
Ok, so the shakedown's going on,
and we...
have...
Programs. There we are.
So "Workshop Safety",
bunch of people interested,
Uhmm...
"Pharmacological Treatment of Drug Addiction", not a lot,
Alcoholic Group, 4 in queue."
So we need to start that,
no regime time slot.
they said we need to create a common room so i'm assuming I can just build...
HEUGH
Maybe just, maybe I could just build this whole thing up,
right here, and connect it to the other area
That would probably be an efficient use of space wouldn't it
Probably gonna clear those tree's out of the way
But who needs tree's it's a prison...
not an arborist
ooooh what was that?
Wow..
Are those bags of blood?
I hope those are liquor bottles
but those are definitely poison bottles right next to it.
five cell phones, 6 prescription bottles
That is a looooooot of stuff.
That is a lot of stuff.
I feel like The Escapists kinda is interplaying inside of this
and they're all having their own adventures.
While me...
I'm just sure I ruin their day and they're never able to go anywhere.
oh wow they got handcuffed ok that was
about all the places that you could
possibly search i imagine i don't know
how much more we can find but we found
about everything
so we need to start a drug treatment
plan as well
pharmacological okay so we got both of
those but I'm gonna what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna build this room up and then
we're going to segment it into two
different areas so it'll be two
different things at once so materials
we're gonna have a we're gonna have a
concrete whoa what the hell is that
why is that there that would they were
supposed to be a wall there who ship
get that out of here not that who not
bad okay so get that out of there
actually probably that I don't think
that needs to be there to rid of them
hope they didn't destroy anything not
it's fine it's all crap that's probably
fine this is build another pipe to
connect the two of those since that
didn't have any other connections
ok so now we need to build walls to
separate everything this will be a brick
wall because it kind of goes with the
theme at a boom and then we need to
create power connections all that jazz
fun fun stuff
little you don't need that we need
electrical cables to be able to run
through here for then
full way No
for hold on
okay that should be enough to do that
that y is blocked blocked from what
well block from what I think it's not
blocked what are you talking about it's
not blocked the electrical cable who
failed one time
yeah whatever you guys are doing it okay
so we need to build walls now so that's
got a brick wall
oh it needs door air I need that after
you're right
door door door door door door we need to
door door door door door is important
door is important we need to door in
here here here
blank and blank . okay says it is going
to be two separate rooms in there as
soon as they install the doors up then
they get what they need to do what has
their garbage in the way of the goddamn
door
right got to get the garbage with the
garbage out of there was a garbage right
therapies get rid of that whatever
they'll figure that out
I I hope anyway yeah they got it ok so
now i need to build another wall to
separate the interior these into two
separate rooms .
ok so that's going to be two different
areas we have ability to go in and out
of each wound
just like that and that and then never
the two shall meet
actually that's how i want it so we're
going to have the different rooms in
here we're gonna have a common room in
here
why couldn't it be built the right there
I don't know why
ok and right now so we got the commons
enabled and then we're gonna put some
more
nice wooden tiles in these we want
people to feel welcome and happy and I
still don't know why the walls are built
properly right there
now we need to create a meeting place
made up of eight chairs
ok does it just do that
all right okay there we go that's not
very organized and I don't think that's
exactly what i need to do but it's good
enough because that's going to be able
who is going there
very good we've made a real difference
here and i think the prison is back
under control
a little bit not quite a hundred percent
you can stay and improve the prison
further we move on to the next facility
when you're ready to move on click on
the Polaroid in the infirmary
you know what I'm gonna move on because
if we're just gonna go to another prison
anyway there's no reason to stay here .
ok let's see what happened to the dawn
did he die like he predicted he would
I'm not a hundred percent sure about
that oh it's villa villa villa negative
ville de blanca Villa Blanca Blanco
I don't remember what is she doing
it's probably
oh i think i left a shakedown on I
probably shouldn't let them all go free
but they are prisoners so
hello vitalia i was close
I've italia how you doing welcome here
is awfully sinister music for whatever
the hell is happening over here
italia
yeah he probably knows that he started
the fire
so that's probably gonna be bad sweet
cheeks I'm sorry i fucked up
hush now they said pops won't last the
week
I know I came to say goodbye you know we
could walk away now
you and me this fucking life it's taken
everything
I'd like that
but i can't i'm a palermo Nico
I knew this was coming with Papa gan and
you an outsider in his place
our enemies would walk right over this
family I can't have that I have to show
them a player most still sits on the
throne
what so you here to fucking whack me
after all we've been through
nico nico nico you're so old school
no sweetheart I'm divorcing you oh
that's actually an interesting twist the
fuck you kidding me
I'm a dead man in here without the
family behind me I know sweetheart but
that's not my concern anymore
oh wow
Oh
as an interesting twist
I wish you to be I wish you to a better
place Pappy all remind me as i walked
right over your bed
oh that's interesting goodbye Nico
fascinating
Oh
chapter 3 gobbles GA BOS I don't know
what that means
gabble gabble Wow CNBC
reporting live from somewhere there
where there's a prison riot alchemical
alchemical state prison staff and
security of withdrawing the perimeter to
wait for military assistance a number of
personnel are still unaccounted for
including company CEO Charles Wallace
rioting erupted following the arrest of
several high-profile judges alleged to
have taken kickbacks in return for
imposing harsher prison sentences
Douglas Benedict currently serving a
life term is believed to be the
ringleader behind the outbreak of
violence
adding fuel to the fire sources say the
criminal underworld has recently been
rocked by a series of high-profile
murders including the attempted
assassination of mob boss Victor palermo
last month
city mayor Calvin Heller released a
statement just a few moments go to those
who question our policies of punitive
reform
this should act as a stark reminder
these men have been housing and food
provided the privilege of paid work
this is how they reward the taxpayers to
subsidize their comforts CEO Charles
Wallace deputy a relative newcomer to
the post has been tasked with restoring
order is yet to be seen whether a lack
of experience will prove costly during
this difficult crisis
oh well god
oh geez oh well this is bad
how do you know it's gonna be war wow
the no-go she was calling my trapped in
here
wow guide ok no cheese
hello they're all unconscious holy crap
it's out of control here nobody is in
charge
we've got multiple casualties and the
remaining guards won't go into the
riding cell blocks
we've had to pull back to the perimeter
figure out what to do and put a stop to
this before it gets out of hand
riot police should be here in a few
minutes okay well I don't know what to
do
how would I know what to do everything's
going to shit there's fires everywhere
oh my god stop the right oh how I don't
know how or jeez oh jeez
- oh girl oh girl I don't know I don't
know what to do
how do I deployment Oh emergencies aah
fire engine
we need fires out first i guess we need
that maybe and lets the rider so just
gonna beat the shit out of the
firefighters
I don't know if that's gonna happen but
we can't let the fire raids or otherwise
it's just going to be bad all around to
go there if you can
oh no they can't they can't even get
inside ok we'll take you 1 cell block at
a time maybe I don't know if any of the
police are gonna actually go in
I don't know if they can no damn it
well I do I don't know what to do well
here we go
they're all we were waiting on the ride
please the first the first of the
response teams have arrived
these guys are ride guards and they're
much more heavily armored use these guys
to start retaking the captured prison
wings
we've also got some paramedics from the
nearby state hospital
I suggest you use them to give emergency
medical attention to your right guards
as they would take the prison
ok we're all gonna go as one now let's
not include these guys all right we're
all gonna go as one
no we're good bye I'll call you when I
need you let's go for it
whoops shit all right let's go for it
let's go let's go
all right we got paramedics and
rygaard's we're going in
maybe the maybe the paramedics would
also like to go treat these guys
all right let's go in taking one block
at a time very slow and methodical make
sure that we got everything counted for
they actually gonna be doing it together
doing something ok so those guys are
healing those guys up so we need to go
right into this swing here so we'll
start by going over there
so far so good make your ways in there
at least I'm still getting paid for this
that's awfully nice
all right who doesn't sound like good
things are happening there's a lot of
people that are dying in there which is
bad
ok so you guys treat that but when they
get all healed up all bring them in and
then we'll give everybody here
oh there's fighting hello stop resisting
get on the ground get on the ground on
the ground
okay good I guess
can we do it youjizz
okay we'll start with this cellblock
well maybe these guys shouldn't be here
I'm beginning to think that maybe there
are not supposed to be there
they're probably not supposed to be
there oh we gotta retake you know that's
why I ok they're good
well that's fine Sorry Sorry have to do
that
bang boom bang boom ok so now get this
one
are these cops ready to roll yet these
guards okay these guys are ready to roll
it over to our cannot enter right
oh geez okay well we'll start we take an
order about staging them in the non
rided area at least these guys are going
there to move it
ok moving in okay so far so good
will bring
see I'm bring in this guy
good okay they're getting medical
attention
so squaring and I don't sound like
robots when they're moving around
moving forward forward what are you
doing
you leave him alone leave him alone
all right we're good were good we're
good control and control and i don't
know i'm being so strategic about this
but I'm just a little worried
oh here we go more rygaard's have
arrived perfect exactly what i needed
because we got a situation going on over
here
get in there get in there buddy booze
you're on your own
you're on your own in this heavily
guarded wing which looks very bad
get in there and get good smash them up
breaking down all right hopefully this
will be okay , send to these guys over
to join the other Rygaard so we'll have
two paramedics to each group hopefully
once they're done doing whatever the
hell they're doing
mayor Calvin Heller is calling ok I
assume this is the CEOs deputy with whom
I'm speaking it
I appreciate this is a very difficult
time and we're all under intense
scrutiny
rest assured you have my full support
and using any and all resources at your
disposal with gain a foothold and we
take in some of the prison and a loss of
life so far is completely justifiable
but before you push on to retake the
rest of the prison
Yuri secure the wings that you have
captured hire some guards and assign
them to the recaptured section from the
deployment screen
they will ensure the captured wing stay
captured once you've taken care of that
pushing to the remaining zones and put
these monsters down these animals can be
rebuilt rehabilitated and they can be
negotiated with i'm working on
authorizing an armed response team that
will put an end to this quick
that seems a little bit extreme I'm not
a hundred percent sure about that but
maybe you know
oh hello
the mayor is brought in some armed
police from the nearby police station
oh boy that seems extreme
be careful with these guys you might
just end up with a bloodbath on your
hands if you let them loose on the other
hand the prisoners may choose to
surrender when they see these guys
coming in
well well that's like is that optional
is that optional if i use these guys do
i have to use these guys because that
seems like it might be a little bit
extreme
these guys over here what are they doing
get in there get in there get in there
you guys need to go you guys need to
move all right so these guys over here
doing their jobs which is good so we
just need to enter here we need to take
a moment for them to heal up and that
this fire is out of control holy shit
that is bonkers
I don't think there's any saving that
that is just done for
holy crap ok so these guys are gonna
push in from the south side so that they
can come in here
hello you've got wounded all over the
prison and more to come no doubt
you can't just leave them to bleed to
death building permit me somewhere on
the site and higher doctors to treat the
injured
we've also seen quite a few bodies for
the sake of their dignity we need to
build a Morgan start collecting them up
you will need to hire some workmen to do
the construction work be sure to keep
them safe
well I it seems like a bit of an extreme
thing to do in the middle of a riot
why would we bring construction crews
who have nothing to do with prisons at
all over into this area
oh man that doesn't seem good at all but
whatever it is what it is can't fight
now link
okay so I'm gonna sub divide that into
different rooms and then work with that
there and then as soon as these guys
decided there stop being a giant babies
push in push come on push in
are you get why you guys don't push me
ok and then these guys need to go in
here
ok who's calling yes
the main bulk of the reinforcements have
arrived you can now call up as many
squads riot police and paramedics as you
need from the emergency tool bar
ok emergencies riot police and
paramedics bring them in
Oh Benedict why is Benedict how did you
get a number
all boy that ain't good listen up we've
got your CEO
well that's not good ol boy oh geez
so this is how it works I asked you give
any problem send anyone in or if I even
smell a cop
I put a bullet in his skull we want an
unmarked vehicle blacked out windows
full tank one hour
I'll be in touch well that's a lot of
demands
well slam drama well this is quite a
situation that they've gotten themselves
into really barricaded in there
boy that ain't good boy
this is completely unacceptable we need
eyes on that canteen so we can see
what's happening
the small security room to the north of
the canteen we need to secure it
deploy some guards in there the man the
CCTV console and we'll get vision of the
whole cell block
okay you got it I need it to the real
quick getting it
I'm on it I'm on a baby yes
let's take a look at the hostage
situation well this is brad there's more
than i thought would come out of prison
architecture last chance to walk out of
here boss man ever played t-ball tagged
with cheese
oh boy well 00
I've never played two ball tag two
bullets for empty chambers used to play
this with jack rabbits
we blow their heads clean off it's not
really a game when it's just killing
things don't seem too fun but you'll
work just the same
let's start with a simple question what
were you doing in that office
Oh No
I swear I don't know anything
Oh burning something I see my own
reflection enough to know what man doing
wrong
oh boy fine who goes first you me
what about this guy
Oh No
oh geez
what do you know just like a jackrabbit
Oh was in those vials
wow I swear I don't know looks running
out still a blooded bullet in there
somewhere and I know what I saw
I couldn't believe my own eyes
the big company man himself here in my
prison looking guilty as fuck
i'm guessing there was more in those
files in just my rap sheet please please
don't
odds are getting shorter Wallace
yeah it's probably gonna be blanks all
the way up to Wallace
I tell you what I'll make it easier for
you
oh well that's that's not even that's
just the logical probability if its
bullet then there's two empties and then
there's a bullet
all right enough with this bullshit yeah
there's there's a bullet right here
if I know how to play this game and I
think I do
it's your turn motherfucker unless you
tell me what I want to know
I can't please oh geez
ok please please don't shoot
it was money it was all money that's it
your valuable commodities the longer any
of you are in here the more profit we
make we were just bending the rules that
file was the proof
so what are we worth what do you get for
keeping us inside 73 thousand dollars a
year per person that's a lot of money
cheese that's more than average salary
each son of a bitch
time for you to start paying back oh boy
oh boy that's no it's not good dog
that's not good okay i need to go
bill to fuck excuse me I need to go
think about workers and such you guys
get to work
don't worry about the ride is fine or
about school was fine urs ride so i need
to put these guys in here
well that guy's dead i didn't know that
guy died holy crap
I had no idea ok but hire guards and
deploy them to the recaptured zones can
have done that
these guys are working in there well
there's only two left holy crap
well that's no good that's no bueno
well that's no point well might as well
hire some janitors I yes clean this up
you are janitors that's the only thing
that I'm worried about okay so we got
more reinforcements over here anyway so
let's get let's just get everybody we
need to get everybody in there
let's get him at least in here with
these guys in here
those guys didn't
move those other guys work in these guys
are working in eventually they're gonna
work into here we're going to hire more
staff guards for here
guards for here ok so of course of goo
damn I forgot right-click also does that
ok move in their little boy
so we got to get to the outside of the
canteen the max security wing is where
we're working on right now and then the
bulk of the group is coming over there
so I'm just going to speed it up so we
can get this done
oh geez staff
okay now push in here we go push in push
in get it aren't we got a good
ok good police cards doing their thing
cookers in there okay okay so this is
just desolate this just needs to be
destroyed
this is all just dead and actually i'm
actually out of time for this episode so
man that we're gonna get to the bottom
of this in the next episode I don't know
when but we're gonna get there and holy
crap this is going nuts but hopefully
everything will be in order very soon
but i have no idea how that's gonna work
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching
let me know how to solve this problem in
the comments below and thanks again
everybody
and as always i'll see you in the next
video bye
there's no way to say that with
that sounds good